- You know what this color
should have been named?
- What?
- Oliver Wood,
'cause it's a Keeper!
(exaggerated laughing)
- Anything that brings
the books to real life,
I'm about it.
- Totally down!
("Bewitched" by Warner/Chappell
Production Music)
- Super excited because
it's just another way
to geek out over Harry Potter stuff.
- This is the kind of dark blue
that I would expect out of "Sirius."
- There's a bunch of different ways
I could see this color leaning.
- This is "Ravenclaw;" it's blue.
- It has to be "Ravenclaw."
- [Eugene] It's a dark blue.
It has to be "Ravenclaw."
- Like, the good version of Bellatrix.
So, that would be Sirius.
- Seriously?
"Sirius?"
- Sirius!
- [Ned] Yay!
- Ooh, I like this color.
It's like blood.
- It's a nice red.
- It's very deep, it's a fall.
- Yes!
- Definitely "Bellatrix."
It looks like I have
chocolate all over my mouth.
- No.
- Someone cast a spell on this right now.
- This? No!
I don't--
- No, no.
- I disagree.
- Yup.
- Nope.
- Wholeheartedly.
- Delete spell.
- Do you feel sad or do you feel evil?
- I feel evil with this, yeah.
- It definitely reads darker on your lips,
which is what I was hoping
for for "Bellatrix."
- It's very dark.
It's very witchy.
- I can't help but think
it looks like a mustache.
- Yay!
- Oh, great!
- [Together] Yeah!
- Haha!
- Now this, without doubt,
has got to be
Slytherin.
- [Ned] Hermione.
No.
- This has to be Nagini.
- It's got the shimmer to it,
so it's got the scaly effect.
- This makes me feel different,
which, I think, is part
of being Slytherin,
and part of Voldemort's crew.
Did we even check that we got it?
- Yeah, of course we got it right.
- Course we got it right.
- Duh.
- Could have made one
for each of the houses.
- Mm hmm.
- You know, because yes,
there's a "Ravenclaw,"
but I'm a Hufflepuff, what
am I supposed to wear?
- It makes me feel different,
and I feel like that's what
being a witch and a wizard
is all about,
is being different.
- Changes the way you
think about yourself.
- "Always."
- My final thoughts are
(speaks Parseltongue).
(hisses)
- Avada Kedavra.
What, I said it.
Death lasts forever, so does this makeup.